le 4 juillet 2020 c'est la journée que
sophie et ariane voulait parfait on est
très consciente avec tout ce qui se
passe que c'est un choix logique mais
drake emotionnellement c'était quelque
chose qui était très déchirant de c'est
un événement qu'on prépare un thé au
minimum douze mois la vase vous savez
avec une magie une demande en mariage le
mariage comptant 90 invités est
maintenant fixée au 3 juillet 2021
marilena accepter le campus reportés à
l'année d'après sans frais donc on perd
pas le dépôt le couple avait choisi le
verger au gré des saisons à oka pour
encourager la consommation locale et
pour la nouvelle propriétaire des lieux
qui a une longue expérience en
planification de mariage c'est la
première fois que je vis seul de faveur
autant de changements de rapports
reporter les mariage d'un ami
les coutures c'est pour les mariés
qu'ils savent pas trop s'en vont des
bagues de fiançailles aux fleurs à la
salle de réception l'industrie du
mariage touchent une grande variété de
services et de fournisseurs situation
jamais vu jamais vécu de cette ampleur
là option consommateurs soit dix fois
plus d'appels que d'habitude
concernant surtout des voyages et des
mariages tout ce qui est annulée
actuellement en raison de l'interdiction
des rassemblements que ce peu importe la
forme du contrat on peut parler de force
majeure c'était imprévisible au moment
où vous avez signé votre contrat avec un
mariage 6 septembre prochain et
considérant les dépôts verser jusqu'à
maintenant cette future mariée ne sait
plus trop quoi faire
est-ce qu'on va avoir le droit tiré mais
ron aussi grands groupes on le sait pas
et si on a le droit
mon conjoint on se demande si
les gens vont être tentés de venir si
vous voulez annuler votre mariage parce
que vous savez que vos invités seront
pas présents que vous pensez que la
journée sera pas aussi féerique que vous
le pensiez à cause de la distanciation
de 2 m par exemple eh bien ça at il pas
quelque chose qui empêche le commerçant
de fournir sa prestation est donc ce ne
sera pas une force majeure la
planificatrice marie gilbert s'occupe
d'une vingtaine de mariages cette année
dont une douzaine qui devait avoir lieu
dans un hôtel de bromont qui vient de
faire faillite
c'est pas seulement de changer de date
mais c'est de recommencer vraiment de
mots assez parce que maintenant il faut
trouver une autre salle à notre traiteur
malheureusement c'est des sommes
considérables que les clients ne savent
pas à ce jour si vont avoir leurs dépôts
qui était comme d'un approximative de
6000 $ on perd toute notre âme et il
faut on fait juste reporté des mariages
hallal et prochainement se retrouver un
dj même le photographe puant suivi puis
fox n'a pas occasionné de frais le seule
inquiétude que moi j'ai finalement c'est
de rentrer dans ma robe
en 2020 on estime que plus de 20 mille
couples québécois unissent leurs
destinées
chaque année ici à nourrice des bagues
si radio canada montréal
[Musique]